i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight thanks for
joining us
now last night's commentary about the
growing correlation between high potency
marijuana use and psychosis especially
in teens oh it sent all the predictable
voices just oh they went apoplectic well
tonight my follow-up will include a
discussion with two of the brightest
minds on the topic but first
sabotaging america that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now the man has trouble with names but
not the names of people he may be met
once or twice right that would be
understandable we're talking about the
names of prominent political figures
including in his own cabinet
i want to thank
the
the
former general i keep calling him
general my
my uh the guy who runs that outfit over
there you may remember
i got in trouble when we were running
against
the senator who was a mormon
uh the governor okay and i took him on i
want to thank
that fellow down under
thank you very much pal our national
security adviser has been in contact
with his counterparts throughout the
world and our allies as has
the general or excuse me i keep calling
them in general
it's so inspiring isn't it and today as
the supply of baby formula reached new
lows the president reached for more
names
now uh you i'm gonna hand it over to uh
secretary
mr secretary i'm gonna have you speak
now and your remarks and then we're
gonna hand it over uh to uh to samara to
my behind me here
now given the public outcry over how
they've handled the baby formula
shortage well hhs secretary javier
becerra was probably thrilled that biden
couldn't remember his name again
the question is
whether or not there was a
this could have been moved quicker well
i don't think anyone anticipated the
impact
of the shutdown of one facility
uh in
uh the the the abbott facility
is just tell you that they understood it
would have a very big impact
they did but i didn't
now that's reassuring
now the only semi-competent person they
had in the administration at this point
i have to conclude with jen saki and
she's gone
his people just keep missing the obvious
remember his dhs secretary alejandro
mayorka still refuses to refer to the
border as a crisis he says there are
challenges and he doesn't know basic
facts when asked
general mark milley and defense
secretary lloyd austin missed the
dangers of evacuating thousands in
afghanistan
and treasury secretary janet yellen
missed a minor thing
you may have heard about it it's called
inflation
i think i was wrong then about
the path that inflation
would take there have been unanticipated
and large shocks to the economy that i
didn't at the time didn't fully
understand
so why of course would anyone be
surprised that joe biden missed the
importance of keeping america's main
baby formula company fully operational
i mean of course he wouldn't they don't
know anything now wonder 57 percent of
americans in a recent cbs ugov survey
describe biden as distracted
51 percent call him incompetent and only
38 says well he's effective
look the public isn't stupid
they know zero accountability when they
see it
biden's cabinet members shouldn't have
more job security than say a college
basketball coach
if a coach
all he does is lose then he blames
others
he's canned right
and everyone from mayorcus to millie
should have been let go long ago
but in bidenland the fact that you're
getting poorer that america is getting
weaker
that's just part of the necessary
transition
you may not be able to fill your tank
but you should be filled with pride over
all the firsts that this administration
has delivered the first female coast
guard commandant
there's more work to be done to ensure
the coast guard and all the branches of
our armed forces reflect the full
strength and diversity including at the
highest levels of our leadership we need
to see more women at the highest levels
of command in the coast guard and across
every service in the armed forces
what happened just hiring the best
whoever they are
but biden's puppeteers don't care about
objective standards or merit
or do we really think that mayor pete
had the background to run the department
of transportation
or that ex-governor jennifer granholm
was qualified somehow to run the energy
department or that the new press
secretary was the most talented
communicator that biden could have had
in that role
now she doesn't necessarily answer
questions she just reads what people put
in her briefing book
okay um
so there are two graphs behind me
what basically what they show is more
supplies being sold on the market
compared to a year ago so um and this is
without abbott
being in the market right now clearly
and we've seen a lot of progress uh
happening as you can see in 2022
compared to 2021
and as you can see up here as well
and so and that's due to our actions
here at the white house so obviously we
we admit that there's still a lot more
work to be done
you think
moms can't find food for their babies
this is third world stuff happening all
across america but don't fret because
it's story time with kjp
operation
fly formula has cut three to four weeks
timelines for nest for nestle product to
move the the europe to europe to 72 hour
periods through fda's enforcement
discretion we will get 27.5 million
bottles from bubs australians
i'm sure mothers across america are
resting easy tonight after that story
now the lack of seriousness in the biden
white house even extends now to the u.s
marine corps
forget being the fierce fighting force
over land and sea the pentagon wants you
to know that the marines main priority
right now is celebrating pride month
even the bullets are rainbow colored
i'm sure president xi is very scared
tonight
woke virtue signaling january 6 hearings
it's all the democrats are capable of
nothing they've done has actually helped
the average american who's really
struggling right now
i missed dollar gas price 350 you know
but
i don't know who's in charge of this but
it's pretty absurd 140 dollars
you fill up my van
that's crazy
i think folks just want to return to
what they consider normal like the
normal of 2019 we had a roaring economy
cheap energy and no new wars
but now they have chaos and crime and
declining standards of living
led by a man who the press relentlessly
and dishonestly promoted as the great
unifier
normalcy that seems to really be a big
part of the pitch the joe biden is
somebody who who will allow the country
to return to normalcy biden by
inclination is a compromiser he's
someone who wants normalcy also a return
to functioning government the biden team
is trying to restore trust more broadly
trust bribery well that's been shattered
hasn't it across the board americans
want solutions and seriousness but
biden's team gives them celebrities and
stunts
mr president
welcome to the white house come on up
here all right
this important month here in america a
lot of our asian american friends have
been subject to real discrimination
hate
only hides when good people talk about
it and say how bad it is it goes down
so thank you
how about how bad it is when democrats
entire plan depends on getting you to
lower your expectations or be happy with
less or lose pride in your history or
chip away at our constitution
now that's bad
i didn't really think it was possible
for an administration to be both
incompetent and conniving
but they somehow have managed it
mouthing all these platitudes about
diversity and sexual identity using
stupid phrases like putin's price hikes
and ultra maga
it's all just smoke and mirrors
a distraction from their ongoing
sabotage of america and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else